bei den zwischen diese verzweifelte
gleichkommt keine pose draufsitzen
ziemlich cool water wochen portion
[Musik]
gleich mal ist nicht ab so angelegt war
richtig auf kannst du nicht so im
ruhemodus lassen dass die freie gewichte
energiesparmodus weiß ich jetzt wieder
eure mal wanne und willkommen zu eurem
absoluten lieblings format klein
cocktail
da darfst du mitmachen drei cocktails
heute sind es perry hatte die allerbeste
idee aller zeiten kann ich mal hier
jetzt mal so betonen denn heute müssen
wir alle einen cocktail zum thema
lieblingsbuch machen und warum weil dann
lauthals oder ein buch herausgebracht
hat und darf mir natürlich und das ist
auch nach wie vor eine beschreibung
verlegen
[Musik]
[Gelächter]
ich verstehe es nicht
hätte ich doch zurück von bietet mit
ihnen genügt und wir machen die man
schon einkaufen im supermarkt unseres
vertrauens und wer will als erstes seine
zutaten vorstellen
hahahahaha
kann ich mich fragen was ist das denn
für ein
[Applaus]
was werde ich wohl frei genommen haben
herr der angebote welche jetzt keine
aber ich habe gemerkt es gibt noch
autoren ihre charaktere nicht immer game
machen
nachdem sich
ich habe hier eine art april so als als
so völler
dass es aber schafft
das ist die tschechische marke
also ich habe dann habe ich dann habe
ich wohl weil das kommt jetzt wieder da
ich habe es nicht verstanden
der verein habe ich wieder geheult weil
alle schieben dann habe ich eine melone
geholt was ganz besonderes ist man heute
wird echzell ding für mich weil ich habe
schon wieder gesehen was wann es hat
eine scheiße machen ich werde diese
ganze spiel ohne benutzen gleis für ein
special treat der in den kopf kommen ich
brauche die ganze dafür mit vieler von
verschwenden deswegen keinen passend ob
der cocktail dann habe ich noch minze
wie immer man kennt und granatapfel die
blauen höre hier aus der kurator blau
daher ist da und dann hab ich noch
elefanten sind gut das war mainz wartet
man derzeit stellt du dahin 210 tagen
vor dem ich dieses mal dass wir hier so
ein tablett für sich hingestellt hier
wieder schön facebook mit dem touchpen
aber ich habe auch das kann man diese
stars
[Musik]
doch zwei großen rädern
ich habe lieber anonym
ich habe lieber deshalb auch zusammen
mit den pausenbereich ist eine im kopf
hast du eine bio limette benutzt gekauft
von der man die schale benutzen kann
nein aber ich hätte auch eine von deinen
bio benutzen können aber ich wollte dich
kenn ich auflaufen lassen
geschafft ein plastik verschwendet
hier ist für mich abfall weil alle bio
produkte die man an plastik verpackt man
diese bringt uns ein polster bezahlten
leute dem abo essen sind die prägenden
ganzen drucker ich habe nicht weiter
dazu tat habe ich ergaben sirup dicksaft
dann habe ich noch die kieler
meerjungfrau und salz
trotz mit 200 nacheinander aufnahme
jungen rollen und somit und somit
beginnen wir wieder mit den boni möglich
die durch viele beginnen also mögen die
des spiegels will
die fein gehackter altes genommen in dem
mixa hat sich 150 gestellt damit hier
die nicht benutzen können
ich hab ihn schon mal bereit nach vorne
gestellt
[Musik]
so wird sich wie aufgedreht und lover
sagte ihr seid und sobald es losgeht
macht ja das ist der dass er über
mehrere etablierte challenge charakter
der immer noch starken leistung alle
gelesen ich auch noch heute es hat sich
so ist in thailand soll das mitglieder
ja ich dachte es eigentlich der theorie
sieht er aus wie matschen musiziert
feuchten ja gut dann wenn er nicht den
einfachen bürger enttäuschen und ich
sage ich einfach nicht jetzt weil sonst
verwandtes jahr ein buch das bisher noch
keiner aber
[Musik]
steven spielbergs die affen hast du
später den obstsalat und mein gott ich
sehe ich mich verschluckt sich da
bestimmt
so ich muss jetzt einmal relativ
schmeckt er auch die kieler
[Musik]
die kielerin
die kinder hat sich für teilchen erst in
zwei jahren durchgesetzt dass leute
heute für das ganze volk mischen sich
jetzt also ich glaube weil mir ist
hoffte ich verlasse mich so kraft haben
ich bin auch wirklich ich habe ja gar
keine zuversichtlich dass wir nicht von
gut waren allerdings bei kelly und harry
potter
wir wissen alle dass das ist doch aber
ich habe halt gemacht die liebe zu
tragen und das sieht nicht aus nach
liebestrank elli gerade so praktiziert
treffen ihn noch mal sehr viel sagt
frank wurde mich verändert die tage von
sich reden und dann sagt er und das geld
ist wichtig das ist ein experiment ich
werde hier nicht immer so gemacht haben
von interesse haben und da so aus wie du
zu den nächsten folgen
eigentlich hatte ich es mit dem h gar
nicht geplant dabei setzt die idee dass
sie wirklich nichts außer hingegen
bringen du musst jetzt da hingucken ich
lese nicht von mir was jetzt passiert
aber wir haben gesagt von acht bis zehn
hast du noch auf sich da ich möchte das
nicht
hatten sie damals gekommen haben wir
haben ja aber ok ich hab' ich habe
einige spruch für wen haltet ihr mich
[Musik]
für eine ganze packung leistungsangebot
ist das anderes eigentlich jahren
dem habe ich habe sollte ich muss
trotzdem trinkt filtern entlassen und
zaubertrank von welchen gewissen king
afa mehr leben es gibt eine theorie dass
harry potter im gleichen universum die
das von könig artus spielt also wirklich
geglaubt haben ein kommentar über 7
[Musik]
tomaten mag ich hatte so verschissen man
wollte was cooles rette mich noch im
supermarkt etwas zurück geschnitten kann
schwere wassermelone
jaja migros das gras so ist eigentlich
in jeder freunde für
ich bin auch dafür dass ich aufhöre ja
ich bin allein in der folge jetzt kommt
man meinen plakaten ein podcast 20
machte ford ka aus polizei und youtube
ist bestimmt wieder verlinkt du steckst
rhein nicht optimal was dann erst einmal
wieder raus aber das kann ja auch wieder
schief laufen richtig weil wir uns schon
nicht gut rein gegen wie so gut raus
gehen
deswegen bin ich gut eine podcast zu
prüfen ich auch gerne das alkoholfreie
bier zu deuten halt aber irgendwas bilde
ich mir gerade ein was ich wie wasser
geplätscher anhört
[Musik]
oder
sprich von dir selbst recht dax ich will
sie nicht [ __ ]
[Musik]
wie ist das geilste was jetzt habe ich
auch langeweile mach mal den kaffee
was ist daran hast dass du dir vorher
geholt hast du schon bist wohl durch die
untermieter mit euch habt doch auch das
habe ich gesehen also
kann denn bemerkte wollte er sich nur
gesunde sachen ans netz dürfen
hallo ich vorbeikomme
ich habe geld dabei hallo ich habe
irgendwie die satelliten kann man das
spricht bände
und das sind unsere
[Musik]
ich muss heim abschieben dokumenten ich
bin auch komplett komplett am arsch
dieses mal muss ich komplett sagen wir
können beide nicht anders sagen außer
dass es einfach hast du einfach gerade
die rote von 2 wurde gezogen
ich glaube einfach nicht dass du so
leute so in einem youtube-video christi
falsche kartfahren war deshalb wird das
was sie gerade stattgefunden hat ist
nicht okay dann wär was war denn das
buch kennt ja das ist das zweite und
zwar politischen oder auch anders gesagt
viel saft tapas auf erste sich veritas
wirkung machen - wo man dabei auf die
zunge
und dann stand ich so hier und dann habe
ich dieses gesetz rein gemacht und dann
dachte ich so die arag experten
weil sie sich auch wirklich so aus und
die terroristen das auch wirklich aus
solchen gläsernen dass zähne
was ist jetzt rein getan damit sich
irgendwas verwandelt
[Musik]
tokio
ich dachte du hast im blick
angetan und da kam es dann also bevor
ich es probieren
ich hab's ja gefiltert auch eine extra
für euch
ich hab's ja gefehlt hat auch eine äxten
auf euch zur hierarchie
[Musik]
gar nicht so schlecht kommt mal es ist
gesund kommt mal es ist gesund und
alkohol solle jetzt bin ich mal gespannt
was für ein buch du danach gestellt
haben ich bin ich machen oder man ist es
ja was sagt ihr worauf würdet ihr euch
festlegen bei dir kommt so oder so nicht
sagt ich gehe manchmal ein tipp ich mach
mal das hier war ina adventures
feuchtgebiete dass wir ja glaub ich ein
guter gast gewesen aber ich nehme das
mal abzudecken das war ab wichtig
hierbei ist halt das wirklich in
akribischer kleinarbeit jedes stück
frucht von der erdbeere bis zur bis zur
cranberry in diverse kleine dreiecke
geschnitten worden ist bei dieser drink
illuminati ist es eigentlich gelesen
haben
was jemals wirklich komplett gelesen
habe dass wir kann ich auch nur das
machen und was die illuminati regierung
hat mit ein paar wenigen aus dem
untergrund das ist gerade passiert dazu
geführt wenn du das bloß weil das
vermischt sich das vermischt wenn ja
dann mit der gesellschaft und dann
einlösen diesen karten ja und und das
ding ist halt einfach dass dadurch halt
die gesellschaft so ein gedruckt wird
und deswegen das blauen das boot
vermischen sich aber man hat immer noch
haben
man hat einmal pro jahr ist bunt sind
meine galerie dieser aber nur so scheiße
ist schon so exakt dass auch sony keine
marktbewegenden impulse gegeben hat das
ist man bei maria ist aber keine waffe
gewinne auch und immer viel verlangt ja
eigentlich wieder so der künstler haben
mit dem umrühren weil haben wieder mal
ab ließ auch jetzt wenn wir bei den
illuminati hier reingesteckt hier ein
freudiges kochte lecker oder mehr lenze
ist beschiss wasser immer mit so muss
macht bestimmt überhaupt möglich am
geschmack aber ich möchte einen kleinen
kugeln zu nehmen sind aber ich habe viel
süßes fruchtsaft bin ich auch kurze
schauer schmeckt auch er einfach nur wie
wasser mit jahre also der in braun da
hat man so viel machen hören eines dabei
deshalb kamen wir zu meinem buch kurz
war
ich habe mich ja und jetzt müssen wir ja
zu schlafen und dann ist er einfach
sushi ich habe mich für den
regenbogenfisch entschieden und zwar ist
die geschichte vom regenbogenfisch das
aktiven der welt aufgewacht habe
kaufmann
abgelegen für stadtkinder wahrscheinlich
nur ein freundschaftsbuch poesiealbum
sagt man glaube ich die
freundschaftsbund nicht gedruckt dass
man wohl hier gab rhein main muss also
ewig die geschichte ins regenbogenfisch
ist dass er ganz viele tolle schuppen
hat die grenzen also in regenbogenfarben
aber halt die glänzen silbern und wieder
glaube ich und auf jeden fall ist
wunderschön und dann fragen halt die
anderen fischfreunde kannst du mir in
der suppe abgeben und sagt am anfang zu
nähe meinen nächsten meine ich sehe
wunderschön aus und dann entfernt seine
freunde von dem king frisch weil wir
halt sagen
der gibt es ja gar nicht sagt dann merkt
der regenbogenfisch das war ziemlich
einsam ist wenn er nichts ab gibt es für
dich mit dem gut identifizieren ich hab
schon mal was von den fans oft krank
wurde ins werk wird getrunken
ja und dann ich bin kein ass game of
thrones und dann überlegt sich das der
regenbogenfisch nochmal und verschenken
jeden seiner fische freunde eine schupp
und deswegen haben alle das sind alle
drei bier und ich habe meine schuppen
hat euch verschenkt die müssen wir nicht
essen dazu muss man sich das nicht zum
trinken essen und das ist so ein sch in
riga das sind quasi so eine blitzer
flosse darstellen
ja und die schimmert
[Gelächter]
so also dass sowohl hier an dem rand auf
zu chancen
also dass das limette sirup und salz und
das trägt man halt wird hatte ich
schwimme hoch zum 3 ich respektiere und
der regenbogen geschichte oh ja du hast
gewonnen und ich dann diesen tagen nicht
mehr benutzen war beim letzten mal
geklärt wo du nicht noch mal löschen
musste
das muss jetzt noch mal machen dass wir
diese folge wer hat für euch geworden
schreibt gerne in die kommentare und
sehen uns das nächste mal wieder wenn es
wieder heißt drei enkel kopfball an
[Musik]